neander directs traffic Mar knocks him
down pops her up with the game on step and
scores BR Maran who came to Toronto as the villain
sticks the stick in the Leaf's
heart [Music] [Applause] what a
game p would not be
denied it's always a dangerous play three on three
in overtime if you're the last guy carrying the
park and your two teammates are forward of you
that was the case right here with nander with this
little cut bad looked like he lost an edge but it
was a great angle that Maron took on him and poso
went in alone he tried to go five hole on the back
end when it wasn't there he did not curl away he
pursued the pp tried to get it back either banking
it off the goal Turner certainly get it back to
the front of the net Marsha able to glove it down
get another look at it here try to go five hole
what an effort by [Music] Boston that's a great
when the compete level there the details were
good defensively this could be a high-powered
offense in the Toronto Maple lefs and the
Bruins they found a way to win a hockey
game and they certainly deserve I mean
what an entertaining game could
have gone in any direction right